TODD KERPELMAN: So what
if I told you there
was a way that
you could compress
nearly any stream of data
by a factor of 10x or more?
Wouldn't that be something
you'd be interested in?
Yeah.
I thought so.
Let's find out more on
this episode of Route 85.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I want you to take a look
at this array of numbers here.
Imagine that we wanted to
send this array of integers
from a server to
your user's device.
Looks like just a bunch
of random numbers, right?
Well, that word
random is actually
the key to compressing these in
an incredibly efficient manner.
As you probably know, a
random number generator
isn't truly random.
Supply a random number
generator with the same seed.
And you'll get the same
results out every time.
And we can take
advantage of that fact
to recreate that list of
integers using a random number
generator.
You see, all I need
to do to regenerate
that array on a
device is to supply
three parameters, the seed for
an agreed upon random number
generator, an upper bound
to apply to these results,
and the length of the list.
I simply supply those
numbers to a method
that looks a little like this.
And I can recreate that
original number stream.
Just like that, I've built
my array of 30 integers using
just two integers and an int32.
That's a 92% compression rate.
Now granted, finding
that initial seed
did take some work.
But you know what?
That work can
happen in the cloud.
So it doesn't really matter.
What's important is
that on the device,
I'm able to
decompress that number
stream in order and time.
And then of course, once
you start looking around,
you can see that
there's a ton of data
you can compress this way.
I mean, need to
compress a text string?
Well, what's a string but a
stream of encoded integers?
Once I have my
stream of integers,
I simply figure out what
seed I need to generate them.
And voila!
I've compressed my string
down into just three numbers.
It's a pretty amazing
savings, right?
Anybody with a username
of StjxmsDZxGDqbpP
will be singing your
praises in their reviews.
And my gosh, if
you think about it,
an image is really just a
stream of numbers broken out
into several channels.
Take a look at this image here.
And you can see how, using
a random number generator,
I have been able to
replace it with just three
sets of integers
for the red, green,
and blue channels respectively.
Now once again, finding the
right seed can take some time.
And I haven't found the
perfect seed just yet.
So if you look at the
results carefully,
you can see that this is not
quite a lossless compression
scheme.
But I think you'll agree that,
for this kind of savings,
these tradeoffs just
might be worth it.
Anyway, I hope you consider
using this technique
the next time you have data
that needs to be compressed.
Remember, the more efficient
you are with your user's data,
the more they'll love you.
Thanks again for watching.
Be sure to check out other
episodes of Route 85.
And remember that, as my
coworkers on the Android team
like to say, perf matters.
All right.
Thanks, guys.
I think we're done.
MALE SPEAKER: Who let him
into the studio again?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I just, I
couldn't say no to Elijah Wood.
MALE SPEAKER: But that's--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Elijah.
Wood.